hey this is preshtalwalker
imagine you want a can that can hold a
fixed volume v
you could design the can to be wide and
short
in other words it would have a large
radius r
and a small height h
you could also contain the same volume v
in another can which has a little
smaller value for its radius
but it would be a little taller to
contain the same volume v
you could also design a can which is
narrower but it would have to be taller
the question is out of all of these
possible designs
which one has the minimum surface area
the question is
what is the best ratio of the height to
the radius which uses the least material
to contain a fixed volume v
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
in any cylinder
the volume is given by the formula
v equals pi r squared h
if we have a fixed volume v
we can solve this equation for the
height so that we get the height in
terms of the radius
the surface area of a cylinder is given
by the area of three different surfaces
there is a top and bottom to the can
which are made up of circles with radius
r
and then there's a side to the can which
we can roll out to be a rectangle
the rectangle has a height h and its
other dimension is equal to the
circumference of the circle
we can add up the areas of these shapes
to get the surface area of the cylinder
we can now substitute in our expression
for the height in terms of the volume
and the radius
we then simplify this equation to get
the surface area in terms of one
variable which is the radius of the can
in order to find the minimum value of
the surface area
we take the derivative with respect to r
and set it equal to zero
this gives us four pi r minus two v
divided by r squared equals zero
we'll solve this equation for the
variable v
to get two pi r cubed
now just to check
we'll do the second derivative and make
sure that it's positive so that we know
this is a minimum
we now have two expressions for the
volume
we have one expression for the volume
where we have the minimum surface area
we have another expression for the
volume which holds true for all
cylinders
we can set these equal to each other
we can now simplify this
to get that the only way this is
possible is if the variable h is equal
to 2 times r
in other words we need our height to be
equal to two times the radius when we
have the minimum surface area
and this gives us the optimal ratio of
the height to the radius is equal to two
so this is the can size which uses the
least amount of material to contain the
fixed volume v
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshellwalker
if you like this video please check out
my books there are links in the video
description